should you quit your job to start your
business so I got a great question for
one of my newsletter readers love you
guys Tom who wrote in to say my problem
is I'm not an app developer a website
developer I have little investing space
even though I believe in this concept
I'm in a doubt to start the business
myself or sell the idea if it's possible
can you please give me advice in the
reality this idea cannot work I've just
got offered a good job and to support my
children and my wife I accepted it that
being said I'm afraid this idea will
stay an idea
greetings Tom from the Netherlands and
Tom went a little bit more detail about
what his idea was all about and the
restaurants he was targeting as his
customers and honestly is background a
guest honestly I read it over once and I
didn't understand it Mir I started
glazing over so I read it over again and
I still didn't fully understand it and
going back to my VC days where I was in
charge of screening the business plans
right most most business plans never
even get a call for a meeting
99% of plans get rejected one of the
most common reasons is the language
isn't great it's got to be something
that people can understand easily it's
something called the grandmother test if
you showed this to your grandmother
would she understand it if you show this
to a complete stranger will they
understand it because I didn't
understand that and so it causes a
confusion if I was gonna invest in you
I'd say no I wouldn't even write back
because it's it's too confusing that
being said it doesn't matter what I
think right you're not asking me to
invest in your business it doesn't
matter if I think this business is gonna
work what matters is do your customers
think it's gonna work what you need to
do is start talking to customers start
talking to these restaurants and see do
they like this idea or not because I can
tell you it's a greatest idea in the
world and if no restaurant ever picks
you up you're not gonna make any sales
you're not gonna build something great
so go start talking to customers now you
just got this job you have a wife you
have children that's awesome a lot of
people say you got you got to quit your
job you got to jump in being
entrepreneur full-time burn the boats go
all-in attack it you know have no
lifelines and make it so important to
you and what I see reality happen is a
lot of entrepreneurs do that and
and they burn through all their savings
and in three six nine months they're
back in the job market trying to find a
job because they burn through all their
savings and their business didn't work
at I actually have two zookas dedicated
just to this the first is on working to
learn and the second is on creating a
startup plan and my quick advice for you
here is you need to keep your job okay
it's pain it's supporting your family
but dedicate half an hour every single
day to your business you need to find
half an hour every single day to devote
to growing your business to talk into
restaurants to finding an app developer
to building your website to see if this
thing is gonna work or not half an hour
every single day you have to make the
time right if you can't make half an
hour every single day to focus on your
business and you don't deserve to have a
great business your wife needs time your
kids need time your job needs time if
you don't have time to focus on your
wife you don't deserve to have a great
wife if you don't have half an hour
everybody to focus on your business then
you don't deserve to have a great
business you need to find that time and
it's not two and a half hours a week
okay half an hour every single day if
you do an hour one day you still do half
an hour the next day you don't give
yourself a break you got to commit to it
so keep your job keep that income coming
in and then half an hour every day start
talking to restaurants do things to grow
your business commit to it and hopefully
gets to the point where then you can
earn some money from it and then quit
your job and take off but it's always
gonna stay an idea until you focus on it
dedicate a time every single day to move
that ball forward believe those are
watching like the video you can
subscribe to the channel by clicking the
link below thank you so much I'll see
you soon
if you want some believe in your inbox
every week to keep you motivated check
out the link below to join my newsletter